Previously, we've shown you how to access data that sits
in a file or a database. But what do you do
when you want to access data that sits in some website,
like Twitter data? We could just go to twitter.com and search
for Udacity, but then we'd have to manually write down
all the data. We could try to rate a web crawler
to go through the pages HTML, but as you can imagine,
that could get kind of complicated. Luckily, many tech companies like
Twitter allow users and developers to access data directly
in a simple, machine readable format. They do so
through something called an Application Programming Interface, or API.
There are several different kinds of APIs, but one of
the most common types, and the one used by
Twitter, is a representational state transfer or REST API. I
know I sound like a broken record here, but
if you'd like to learn more about the nitty gritty
behind REST APIs, I'd recommend you take the data wrangling class with MongoDB.